108° right there we just got the brand
new M3 MacBook Pro that starts at
$1,600 and today we are going to answer
some very important questions first off
we are going to take off the back cover
and see if this machine still has the
issues that we had previously with the
ssds and with that Apple made a weird
decision they only put in a single fan
into this 14in where all of the previous
ones had dual fan so we are going to see
if this thing can actually keep up with
the performance of the M3 that uses more
power with that single fan and how much
better it is compared to the machine
that it is replacing now thankfully this
new machine has an HDMI port and a SD
card slot compared to this one which is
nice but unlike the previous 14-inch
MacBooks we don't have three Thunderbolt
ports we only have two and it can only
support One external display now with
that my biggest concern is the M2
MacBook Pro hit
104° C it got super hot with that single
fan so will the new 14in get super hot
as well we will be testing that all
right the screws are out let's go ahead
and pop up this cover here moment of
truth let's pull this back and Bam look
at that that looks more simple than
before but de is it just me or this fan
looks smaller than the ones in the 14 in
I don't know man I guess we'll have to
see yeah it to me this thing looks kind
of tiny now we have a single heat sink
going to the M3 chip and we have a lot
of empty space right around here it's a
different motherboard setup and then
right here in the top Corner we have two
nand chips now that is a great thing
because Apple showed up on stage with
two but we don't know that could be the
one terabyte model or the two terabyte
and with the M2 MacBook Pros and airs
they only put one in and that gave us
really slow speeds and that mattered not
only for benchmarks but also transfers
it would slow down incredibly compared
to the M1 and then from multitasking we
would have major slowdown so I'm glad
that they fixed that now looking at the
bottom here we have some pretty big
speakers and we will compare to the 14in
hopefully the speakers are just as good
as before and you know what these chips
look smaller than the ones in the
previous Macbook so let's go ahead and
let's pop these up and compare them so I
took off all the screws from these
covers and now let's pop this one open
and compare it to that model that it is
replacing and right away we can see that
yes the new SSD storage nans are much
smaller than the previous ones that
Apple has been using for years I mean
they are tiny and we will test out the
performance now with that looking at the
fans yes this thing does look smaller
than the single fan with um the 13-in
MacBook Pro now as far as actual fan and
performance this could still do better
we'll see the RPMs maybe it spins up
really high but I also noticed that the
speakers over here they are fairly small
they're probably similar to the other
14in compared to these massive
enclosures that we have on the 13in and
this thing looks a little bit sparse the
new $1600 spec we have so much empty
space compared to jam-packed here with
the 13in model now I'm also noticing
some differences in the heat sink setup
with the new 14-in M3 the bar is shorter
compared to the 13in where it comes way
far out but with that the actual bar
itself is thinner not as wide on the new
$1600 14in than we had with the 13-in
model so I wonder how that is going to
affect it now we also know that the M3
chip has 25% more transistors 25 billion
but the actual thermal block size by
itself is identical and now let's remove
the 13in that's being replaced in
compared to the previous 14 in and look
at that guys my goodness there is a lot
going on right here first off we see
that we have dual fans compared to a
single one it's way more packed in once
again we have the much smaller new
storage chips compared to the larger
ones and if you guys look on the higher
end Pro 14in we have extra Nan slots
right here Apple of course cut that back
with all the M2 series but if you were
to upgrade to higher storage you would
get faster speeds whereas with the M3
version I don't see any other slots so
even if you upgraded to terabytes you
are are not going to get more
performance now looking at the speakers
they look identical and that is a great
thing but Apple has been known to make
some adjustments in software if they
want to differentiate their lineup so we
will be testing that make sure you guys
are subscribed with notifications
enabled cuz we're going to make a ton of
great comparison videos now if you look
at the prips um thermal block it is
massive compared to the one on the M3
and we have the Dual heat pipes coming
out to the Dual fans that can dissipate
so much more heat and that is why I
loved the 14in at that $2,000 price
point it was quiet silent pretty much
and it stayed super cool now as a
positive the fan looks pretty much
identical to the one on the pro laptops
but I am still worried about this M3
chip because it is using more power for
more performance with a single fan and
it would have been easier for Apple to
keep a dual fan layout instead of going
with a single one than trying to you
know change it up so with that said
let's go ahead and set this thing up and
we are going to be doing some tests but
first I want to show you guys the helm
case for MacBooks from our sponsor andar
which is the most luxurious case I've
ever seen made from 100% full grain
leather that easily Clips onto the top
and bottom of your MacBook for 360°
protection so you don't end up with a
bunch of scratches like we did on this
one and it even comes with cutouts for
all of the ports speaker grills and air
vents you can get it in up to nine
different colors for every MacBook
design since 2016 with a 90-day return
policy so check it out using the link
below with the code maxtec for a 15%
sitewide discount all right guys we are
up and running and I'm going to start
with a Blackmagic disc speed test let's
go ahead and run this and right at the
gate we have
3,374 for the right and a little bit
disappointing
2,928 for the read speed with that said
let's pull out the 13-in MacBook Pro and
it looks like on this one we have
2,449 for the right and
2835 so the read speeds are very close
but for the right we are getting about 7
800 megab per second more which is is
good now the thing is if you have the M2
with 256 gig and the single nand that
one was so slow about
1,400 and it's only if you upgrade to
512 with dual n that you get this kind
of performance and now let's open up TG
fan Pro and I'm curious about that
single fan dang look at that crazy fan
6,800 RPM I haven't seen that in a while
and it goes down to 2300 00 right now
it's off just chilling which is great
let's take a look at the M2 Pro with the
Dual fans here we have
5,779 for the left side and 6200 for the
right side definitely not as fast as the
one in the M3 so they're using probably
the same fan and just kicking up more
and on the previous 13in oh man this
thing is
7,200 RPM that thing is a little scream
compared to this now I just enabled Max
fan speed on this 13in we're going to
see how annoying it sounds compared to
the new one I don't know if you guys can
hear that but it definitely has a high
pitch wine and it's coming from that
right hand side and now for the m314 in
I don't know how much you guys can hear
that with our studio shotgun mic but
this thing definitely has less of a
high-pitch sound it does sound like it's
moving more air and might be slightly
louder but but definitely less annoying
and I just maxed out the 14in with a pro
chip and even though this thing has two
fans it is actually quieter than the new
M3 with a single fan and the fans are
actually set up differently to kind of
offset the noise and to be fair with
this MacBook it never hit maximum fan
speed anyways because it had dual fans
and now let's get into our thermal
testing I have the latest version of
cinebench opened up right here here I
also have TG fan Pro and we just got the
update to be able to see the
temperatures and with that we have MX
power Gadget to see what the frequencies
are going to run at this is going to be
super interesting so let's go ahead and
run our CPU 10minute stress test now
right away I am seeing
3.64 GHz for the performance cores with
everything maxed out now that is crazy
because with the M2 it ran a 3.5 Peak
but only 3 .2 if you're actually pushing
it so this has a smaller dip and even
though we have the same amount of
performance cores with the M3 they are
running quite a bit faster and as far as
temperatures we are at 98° C right now
it has literally only been under 30
seconds now we have 101 the fans kicked
up right away which is great dang we
have 105 right there for a second so
it's definitely getting hot the M2 13in
the highest ever reached was 4 106 now
108° right there um yeah this thing is
definitely running hotter the fans are
spinning up earlier 107 108 that never
happened with the 13in so yes this thing
does put out more heat we are running at
I saw 20 21 Watts um for the CPU that is
right in line with the M2 and that is a
little bit surprising but now we're
seeing that it's dropping down a little
look at this guys our fans just keep
ramping up I absolutely hear them right
now they're almost maxed out and this
proves that yes this machine is thermal
throttling just a bit because 108 is the
highest that you can reach before it
slows down and we see that in this line
that the frequency was dropping down
because it got too hot so if Apple did
keep two fans in here like the other 14
in that would have helped out but now we
are cooling down we're at 99 98 still
hot so when the Fan's running loud it
does help but keep in mind this is only
a CPU test we're not testing the
graphics so if you're running both like
in a lot of real world applications like
Lightroom which we're going to test in
tomorrow's video this might get a little
crazy and now I pulled out my thermal
camera so let's see what we get it's
been about 5 minutes and I'm seeing 35
34° C right there and actually the chip
it's itself um doesn't look crazy hot
we're getting way more heat out of that
exhaust um so the it is dissipating heat
fairly well with the CPU workload um so
I'm actually surprised by that it means
that we're not going to get chassis
throttling in this machine because it's
getting that heat out of there even
though we're seeing a little bit of
throttling and what this really means is
if you're waiting for an M3 MacBook Air
that is fanless that is going to have a
lot of heat buildup more throttling than
before and apple might even choose to
just downclock or limit that chip in
that chassis because of this so if you
care about performance then you should
probably just buy one of these instead
of waiting for that machine all right
guys we are almost done here and one
interesting thing is this processor is
rated at 4.0 GHz we never saw higher
than
3.64 so let's get this score and then
we'll see what we can actually get yet
but one thing's for sure this machine
definitely runs louder than the other
14in uh Pros that we have tested all
right the test is done and we have
638 points now if that seems low this is
the updated much harder cine bench and
looking over here it gets closer to the
M1 Max with this M3 that is impressive
in tomorrow's video will'll compare it
to the M2 Pro which technically should
be faster but we shall see and I'm going
going to go ahead and just run that
single core test super quick and right
there 3.7 3.71 we got higher than with
the multicore but it is not hitting 4
GHz and that means that that 4 GHz is
only for very simple quick single core
tasks more like for a geek bench
Benchmark it's not actually running
there even though it is cool so what did
we learn in this test we have a lot of
internal differences uh we have those
ssds that are updated and new
and yes the single fan is loud and this
machine can throttle unlike the previous
14-in with the pro chips make sure you
guys click that subscribe button above
check out that cool laptop case Anders
with the link down below and we shall
see you guys in the next
[Music]
video